one month from today well no Tyler
Eifert Michigan versus Notre Dame will
know that result how you been I'm good
I'm excited to watch that game to get
that robbery we're going here yeah I
know I know I'm glad that Notre Dame
decided to start playing the game again
Tyler that's right
was it another name oh yeah it was it
was but that's all good how are you
feeling let's talk about you a little
bit here how are you feeling here I'm
feeling good the back feeling good we've
you know just kind of bonafide practice
a little bit for me I guess we're not
taking as many reps but still still
getting a lot of good work in and doing
a lot of stuff off the field I started
Pilates this offseason which has really
helped me by the way I Tyler another
learn I guess you and I have in common
other than you know going to great
institutions of higher learning they'd
have great football programs I do that
too that is no joke that's great for the
core that's good for you yeah I was I
was super against it you know it's just
rather just go crush weights and those
types of things right I finally um
finally caved and it really helped me
know I mean it really does work on your
corne it helps your back I mean the
whole thing you know want one exercise
helps the entire flexibility in your
body I mean like what what do you find
the toughest part about it Tyler I think
it for me it's just you know I've been
rehabbing for such a long period of time
that it it can sometimes get monotonous
and you're just kind of you've been
doing these exercises for so long that
you're just kind of doing them now but
with the Pilates it kind of it reminds
you how to engage your core and like the
muscles that are deep mm-hmm
I don't know deep in your core that
stabilize the spine so just taking a
little bit slower approach and and
really understanding that I think it's
helped yeah and say to back surgeries is
no joke
Tyler I mean how how in the world do you
come back from that each time and know
that you're gonna go out and play our
sport we're gonna take hits potentially
on those spots yeah it's been to to in
the NFL and I had one in college so it's
3.now but it's I don't know it's always
tough having a setback like that and
then going through the rehab process you
want it to you want to be healthy right
away and you want to be back to your old
self but it doesn't happen overnight and
you know just the little progress that's
made you know you got to feel good about
and then eventually over a long period
of time you know it finally comes back
and you get back to yourself and then as
far as in the game situations on the
field you almost you don't even have
time to think about it once you're once
you're good to go you're you're back in
it full go so on the field I really
don't even think about it
okay and you start it on pop and then
all of a sudden you showed up on the
practice field why did you start on on
pop if you you were able to get on the
field so quickly during training camp
Tyler yeah there was no there's no real
lingering issues it was just that was
the way that we just the plan that we
decided to go with just kind of easing
into it I guess and they wanted to work
because I wasn't here for the entire
offseason I was working out somewhere
else I think the team wanted to work me
out pretty hard and have me show that I
was I was good to go and if I could get
those workouts that I'd be alright for
practice Tyler Eifert Bengals tight in
here on the Rich Eisen show and you know
let's let's talk about what this team is
going to look like Tyler I mean uh it
does appear that you know we're just
gonna try and run it back with the
Bengals in the same with this a lot of
the same personnel that we've seen the
last couple years including the head
coach Marvin Lewis who a lot of folks
thought was never going to come back
this year how has that been playing out
where the coach is still there and you
guys have another opportunity to perhaps
keep him there
yeah us as players are are definitely
excited about it you know we love Marvin
and it's also nice having a coach that
you know what to expect and we know that
we know the routine and the schedule and
all those types of things so not having
to go through that change is nice and
then you know we have we have a lot of
really good players if you just look at
our roster on paper but we just got to
find a way to put it all together which
I feel like we've been saying for a
couple of years but we really do have
some talented guys and actually if we
got a really good team so just being
able to put those pieces together and
play as a unit and kind of get on a roll
would be nice
well you know I mean the the the sense
many have is that Marvin's a little too
lacks on the players I've known him for
a very long time and I know that that is
not you know particularly the case for
some but others just seem to continue to
stay on the roster and stay on the team
despite those nagging 15-yard penalty 'z
that crop up all the time at the worst
possible times Tyler I mean can you
speak to Marvin's hold on the team and
and his his disciplinary process there
Tyler I mean I think it's a little bit
different for each guy I mean obviously
we have a lot of different type of style
of players on the team and especially
those penalties that are in the game
there that are art they are avoidable
but I mean it's just I don't know
they're just tough but it's hard to
discipline a guy for them for something
that happens in a game unless it's after
the the whistle you know that those two
kind of things are tough but I don't
know I feel like Coach has a really good
hold all that we all respect Marvin a
lot of guys have a really good
relationship with them and I think we'll
be just fine okay Tyler I for a couple
more minutes left here with the Bengals
tight end is it true you have a mullet
working I see it in your your
photographs is there is there a party in
the back business on top situation going
on with you right now yeah there is I
got a situation going right now
kind of started off as a haha kind of
thing and I just I just started to kind
of embrace it and um you know everything
that goes along with with having a mole
at the lifestyle and what is that
lifestyle for somebody who's physically
I mean a follically challenged like me
Tyler what we throw what is that
lifestyle like the moment lifestyle I
don't know it consists of a couple
things you know I you know being
enjoying the outdoors drinking cold beer
okay being being patriotic enjoying
fishing hunting you know those kinds of
things and if you had no mullet it
wouldn't be as enjoyable no it's as
enjoyable button it just you know it
kind of puts just puts it out there as
is there a loved one in your life that's
given the if you will blue checkmark to
the mullet Tyler no honestly though
coach Gundy for Oklahoma State I saw him
in a press conference last year and that
was that was honestly who inspired it I
was like I gotta try that Mike Gundy was
the mullet sort of inspiration he's a
man he's 40 I know that he so you drink
40s and he's 40 is what you're saying
yeah yeah that's the moment okay so what
can we do here before I let you go for
the Michigan Notre Dame game Tyler well
is there something we could do here
between me and you I'd say maybe we
could I don't know we could compare 40
times but that's already settled yeah
that's settled then that's checked it we
checked that box checks that box I would
say what do you think
I know I can't grow a mullet I can't do
that we could do an avatar situation
right I mean you're you're on Twitter
I'm on Twitter we could do one of those
situations where
somebody's gotta wear an article of
clothing of our choice that's always
good and in an avatar we could do that
even though you know your home its first
game for Shay Patterson there's gonna be
I'm willing to just put my pride on the
line against you excuses already know
I'm Tyler
they're called facts they're called
facts the game is in Indiana there's a
new quarterback from Michigan there's a
lot on the line that's the beauty of
this game that you ran from so is that
it's right there on the very first game
of the season I'm willing to do this if
you are I'm in so what is it we got it
you gotta wear a t-shirt or the other
team yeah a t-shirt hat some form of
clothing must be worn of a clear
photograph that's placed in an avatar
for a week okay when you take one step
further into a video and you got to say
go Irish
okay okay okay yes the video but the
video and then you must say go blue and
then we'll get somebody to play the
fight song in the background how's that
and then we tweet that out that's the
bet boom real job off like okay that's
the deal okay okay and you've got to do
you've got to do yours in some form of a
Pilates pose as well okay okay get there
on the Cadillac as they say or get there
on you know get there on any sort of
equipment and we'll bang that out okay
all right all right Tyler you take care
like it alright thanks for having done
you guys it's Tyler Eifert Bengals Tyler
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience